صور مباشره من غزه
لتشييع ضحايا العمليه التي نفذتها فجر
اليوم السلطات او اسرائيل
وحتى الان عدد الشهداء وصل الى ثلاثه عشر
واكثر من 20 مصاب هشام اذا ارتفاع عدد
الشهداء الى 13 بدات بدات تشيع جثامين
الشهداء اطلعنا على الاجواء العامه
بالفعل وسيله منذ يعني قليل بدات عمليه
تشييع الشهداء بدات في مستشفى ومجمع
الشفاء الطبي ومن ثم انطلقت في مسيره
جماهيريه حملت اجساد وجثامين هؤلاء
الشهداء على الاكتاف
وتوجهوا من مجمع الشفاء الطبي الى هنا الى
المسجد العمري الكبير حيث
ستكون هناك تابين لهؤلاء الشهداء ومن ثم
سينطلقون من المسجد باتجاه مثواهم الاخير
في المقبره شمال قطاع غزه هذه المسيره كما
ترونها في الصوره هي مسيره غضب لبعض من
الجماهير وعائلات هؤلاء الشهداء وهناك
حاله من الغضب العارم في غزه جراء اغتياله
هؤلاء الشهداء هم قاده في سرايا القدس
اغتلتهم اسرائيل
دمرت منازلهم وشققهم السكنيه واصابه
العديد من العائلات في قطاع غزه في عند
الساعه الثانيه بعد منتصف الليل وبالتالي
كان الجميع نيام هناك غضب
وهناك غضب من هذه الجماهير وبالتالي صاروا
في مسيره جماهيريه من مشفى الشفاء باتجاه
هذه باتجاه باتجاه المسجد العمري الكبير
حيث ستكون هناك بعض الكلمات يلقيها بعض
القاده في فصائل العمل الوطني الفلسطيني
وبعض من العائلات ومن ثم ستكون هناك
الصلاه على هؤلاء الشهداء ومن ثم سينطلق
موكب التشييع بعد نحو تقريبا نصف ساعه من
الان باتجاه او تقريبا بعد ساعه من الان
باتجاه
المقبره هؤلاء الشهداء كما قلنا حتى الان
الشهداء الذين
ستنطلق سينطلق موكب التشييع من هنا من
المسجد العمري الكبير هم جل هؤلاء الشهداء
ما عدا القياده البارز في سرايا القدس
جهاد الغانم الذي سيشيع هو وزوجته في رفح
جنوب قطاع غزه حيث استشهد هناك في اثناء
خلال القصف منزله في تلك المنطقه في جنوب
قطاع غزه هنا سيشيع خليل البهتيني القائد
البارز في سرايا القدس والتي تتهم اسرائيل
بالمسؤوليه عن اطلاق صواريخ باتجاه
اسرائيل وايضا تتهم بانه مسؤول
ويسعى لتنفيذ عمليات في قلب اسرائيل وايضا
هو مسؤول عن تنفيذ والاتصال مع
عناصر من المقاومه في الضفه الغربيه كذلك
هو ايضا طارق عز الدين هو مسؤول عن
التواصل مع المقاومين في الضفه الغربيه
تتهم اسرائيل بهذا الاتهام وبحسب مصادر
قالت للجزيره في حركه الجهد الاسلامي فهو
كان بعد ايام قليله سيصبح عضوا في المكتب
السياسي للحركه
وكان سيسافر الى الخارج حيث سيجتمع المكتب
السياسي في الخارج بعد ايام وبالتاكيد
هناك غضب عالم في شارع فلسطين
من الشهداء عدد من الاطفال كذلك والنساء
كانوا نيام في
منازلهم الان الحديث عن عشرين مصاب كيف هي
اوضاع هؤلاء المصابين
بالفعل وسيله هناك ثلاثه عشر شهيدا من
بينهم اربع اطفال واربع سيدات وهناك اكثر
من عشرين اخرين اصيبوا بجراح مختلفه من
بينهم ثلاث اطفال وسبع سيدات وكنا في مجمع
الشفاء الطبي
والتقينا بعدد من الاطباء هناك وكانت بعض
العمليات تجرى لعدد من الجرحى وما زالت
اعداد من هؤلاء الجرحى حالتهم بين حرجه
وخطيره وبالتالي الاعداد ما زالت مرشحه
للازدياد بسبب هذه الحالات الخطيره جراء
الاصابات كما نعرف فان
عمليه الاغتيال تمت بعد منتصف الليل وكنا
قد زرنا منازل هؤلاء الشهداء هناك يعني
انهيار كبير
واطلقت الطائرات الحربيه
صواريخ باتجاه هذه المنازل والدمار كبير
وواسع في هذه المنازل والشقق السكنيه بعض
خليل البهتيني منزله جزء كبير منهم مدمر
وعدد من المنازل المحيطه بهذا المنزل ايضا
دمرت جراء هذه الغاره الاسرائيليه وكذلك
طارق عز الدين يسكن في شقه سكنيه في منزل
مكون من عده طبقات ست طبقات على الاقل 30
شقه سكنيه متواجده في هذا المبنى وجميع
هذه الشقق السكنيه طالها الضرر وجزء كبير
منها حتى النجار
طارق عز الدين القيادي البارز في سرايا
القدس هو طبيب الدكتور مسؤول مستشفى
الوفاء
واستشهد هو وزوجته وبعض من ابنائه
وبالتالي
الاصابات كبيره واصابات مباشره وعدد كبير
من
المواطنين الذين يسكنون في هذه المنازل
عولجوا حتى بعض منهم بالجراء اصابات طفيفه
علجوا في المكان بالتالي ما زالت هناك
يعني بعض العمليات تجرى في مستشفيات قطاع
غزه التي تقول وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
انها تعاني ولا تزال تعاني جراء الحصار
الاسرائيلي المستمر على قطاع غزه وهناك
نقص حاد في الادويه والمستلزمات الطبيه
وكذلك تقول وزاره الصحه ان اسرائيل مستمره
في منع ادخال الاجهزه الطبيه التشخيصيه
الى مستشفيات قطاع غزه منذ اكثر من عام
وهناك ايضا محاوله
لرفضه لادخال الاجهزه بالاضافه الى
الاجهزه فان المعدات وبعض الادوات
المستخدمه في هذه الاجهزه وقطع الغيار
ممنوعه ايضا هي من الدخول
وتؤكد الوزاره ان هذا يشكل تحدي كبير امام
عمل طواقم الطبيه ومتابعه الجرحى لسيما
ونحن نتحدث عن تصعيد اسرائيلي وهناك تخوف
من ان يكون هذا الت الاسرائيلي يستمر عده
ايام
وتحذر وزاره الصحه من ان هذا التصعيد
سيؤثر بشكل كبير وانها لن تصبح قادره على
الاستمرار في تقديم الرعايه الطبيه للعديد
من المصابين والمرضى وهي اصلا اوقفت
العلاج في العيادات الخارجيه
للمرضى وبالتالي المرضى العاديين الذين
ياتون الى المستشفيات هم عدد كبير منهم
الا في حالات الطوارئ هم لا يتلقون العلاج
في هذه المستشفيات جراء تفريغها او ادخال
جزء منها الى
افراغه لي تلقي جرحى التصعيد الاسرائيلي